Now that we've discussed some of the models of motivation, let's move on to the
study of some of the things that motivate us, such as our motivation to eat. We
can think of hunger as a homeostatic need. And we can look at this as having a
feedback and a feed-forward signal. Let's start with a negative feedback
signal. The negative feedback signal tells us when to stop an activity. And in
regards to food, the signals are generated as the food passes through our
mouth, stomach, and small intestine. One of the major negative feedback systems
signals the release of the hormone, cholecystokinin. Or cck for short. From the
stomach and intestine walls. One thing that cck does is reduce the pleasure
from ingested food so that an animal will stop eating. There are also some
specific chemical satiety signals released by eating particular types of food.
However. That we may have a satiety signal for one type of food, it doesn't
hold for all foods. Therefore, we see that we may be full for one type of food
but not for another type of food. So, we may be sated for one type of food and
therefore we turn to another type of food. Let's go to Greg for an example